it is international women's week so
obviously Brendan I'm gonna have to
throw to you first uh Hillary Clinton
chimed in on what's going on with the
chicks these days and uh here's a doozy
for you
finally I'm so glad that
Elena zelenska is here because women are
women and and children are the primary
victims of conflict and of climate
change and there is no place that
unfortunately tragically shows us that
more dramatically than Ukraine today
it's so incredibly stupid that words
actually Escape me women climate is
coming for women conflicts coming for
women seems like usually it's an awful
lot of men out there doing the fighting
but Brendan as a woman this is a very
exciting month for you what do you make
of Hillary the war in Ukraine is mostly
about women women have penises
Etc
I I you know I'm curious of her comments
they say that uh climate's coming for
women more than men I don't know I feel
like men are a little bit heavier and
they have tend to have more uh muscle on
their body you know just basic science
so that means we sweat a little bit more
when it gets when it gets hotter out so
I take I'm offense to that I also saw a
great meme just right before I came on
it was like International women's day
was yesterday but it's actually today
because it would have been took too long
to get ready ah there you go there you
go it's
it's didn't some crazy trans person
trans woman win an international well
we'll get to that we'll get to that I'm
sorry I'm jumping the gun you're jumping
ahead Sarah just this endless nonsense
like linking these things somehow
climate change has something to do with
Ukraine and that really has something to
do with women how do they do it the
magic trick right in front of us I'm
convinced Dave that they have uh they
have like a chart and on the chart they
have the buzzwords so they have the
special interest group groups they have
women they have minorities so they have
black people they have Hispanics they
have the
lgbtqia plus however many acronyms they
have now and they have all of the all of
the categories and then they have issues
so they have climate change they have
War they have the economy they have all
of these issues and they just pick on
one day whatever day it is they go you
know what I'm going women and climate
change and they just link
that they're talking about to those two
things I'm convinced of it because
that's the only thing that makes sense
that doesn't make sense mind you but
it's the only thing that makes the most
sense nothing else makes sense on this
all right let's get let's get to the if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell